the tradition of sufism has brought some
of the most amazing examples of artistic
expression in history from music to
visual arts and probably most famously
literature
while the mystical experiences pointed
to can never be fully articulated or
expressed in language as rumi himself
points out in the opening to his mas
navi nonetheless sufis across history
have loved to express their
various states of consciousness
particularly through poetry
whether it be the tarjuman al-ashwach by
evan arabi the ata'al kubra by ibn
al-farid the already mentioned mass navy
by
or the many verses by the turkish poet
yunus emre but one of the most revered
and important works of sufi poetry in
history one whose imagery has inspired
innumerable mystics and artists since
then is the monumental work called the
conference of the birds written by the
13th century persian poet faridudin atar
a true classic and masterpiece not only
of sufi poetry but of persian literature
in general this work serves as a
beautiful account of some of the most
foundational and fundamental
doctrines and ideas in sufism while also
being incredibly engaging and beautiful
to read at the same time so join me as
we dive deeper into the minds of atar
and his conference of the birds
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do
[Music]
when it comes to the world of sufi
poetry rumi is probably the most famous
around the world translations of his
works have been best sellers in the
united states and in europe but to those
familiar with the topic atar isn't too
far behind him his works having been
translated various times and often being
referenced in other media or literature
indeed the great rumi himself saw athar
as one of his main inspirations and atar
in general is often upheld as one of the
all-time greats of persian poetry
there's a lot to be said about the
conference of the birds as we will see
but there isn't as much to be said about
a todd himself we know very little about
his life beyond legendary hagiographical
accounts he was from the city of
nishapur in what is today north eastern
iran and spent the majority of his life
in that city his year of birth isn't
certain but it appears that he began his
life sometime in the early to mid 12th
century and that he lived into the first
decades of the 13th he doesn't seem to
have been all that famous outside of his
hometown during his life although at the
same time rumi who was a younger
contemporary held him in great esteem so
he must have been famous to some degree
his personal name was muhammad and he
was given the honorific name fariduddin
which doesn't give us much information
either but his pen name and the name by
which he is known to most people is atar
which means something like perfumer and
carries with it connotations of being a
seller of perfumes or drugs as in
medicine essentially so it's quite
possible that he came from a family of
pharmacists and that he himself might
have held this as his profession indeed
he makes reference himself to the fact
that he wrote his poems in a daru
a persian word meaning a chemist store
or drug shop essentially other than this
it's hard to say anything with certainty
it's said that he traveled for a period
all around the islamic world from mecca
to baghdad to egypt and much more
perhaps he would have studied under
certain sufi masters but his
relationship with sufism is also a point
of debate it would seem obvious that he
was involved with sufism in some way
given the prominence of sufi themes in
his poetry as well as the widespread
popularity of sufism at the time but
some scholars argue that he may be more
of an interested and educated outsider
being inspired by sufis their lives and
teachings but not being initiated into a
sufi order per se i tend to fall into
the less skeptical camp and i believe
that we can probably call at todd a sufi
that he was personally involved in that
tradition in some way
it seems likely to me based on his
poetry and the way that he seems to be
acquainted so deeply with many of these
themes in any case he became incredibly
important for the continuing development
of sufism after his time because so many
later personalities was inspired by him
the way a todd is able to express or
explore the practical and philosophical
aspects of sufism through
colorful stories and beautiful poetry is
astoundingly impressive and this was not
lost on figures like rumi indeed rumi is
just one example of a figure who saw a
todd as one of his main inspirations and
who would in some ways continue the
tradition that ethtod pioneered
expressing sufism through poetry in the
persian language
and while we're on the subject one of
the most famous stories about a todd is
that he supposedly actually met with
rumi in real life it is said that rumi
who was a young boy at this time and his
father were forced to flee their
homeland in balch due to the mongol
invasions and while passing through
nishapur they are thought to have
visited a todd who of course recognized
the spiritual power of the young
jalaluddin while this story is of course
possible it is most likely a legendary
account that connects in a physical
sense the two giants of sufi poetry but
even if their meeting wasn't physical in
real life so to say the intellectual
impact that a todd had on rumi can not
be overstated
just like his birth the death of
faridudin a thought is somewhat of a
mystery the most popular account is that
he died as a result of the mongol
sacking of nishapur in 1229
others think that he died a number of
years earlier but it seems at least that
he died somewhere around the year 1220
give or take a few years
so what are those influential works that
he supposedly composed in his drug store
there are essentially seven works that
are authentically attributed to attad by
modern scholars
one of them is a work of prose called
the tadkirat el auliya the memorial of
the saints or the memorial of god's
friends which is a series of
hagiographical accounts of the earliest
sufis but the rest of the works are
poetry most of which was written in
persian this includes a devon or
collection of poems in various genres
and meters the asrar nama the book of
secrets the mukhtar nama the choice book
and the most famous of his works the
long poem that goes under the name the
conference of the birds
the original title for this work is
manta attair an arabic phrase meaning
something like the speech of the birds
and which is taken from the quran in
surat anam verse 16 it says quote and
solomon was david's heir and he said men
we have been taught the speech of the
birds and we have been given of
everything surely this is indeed the
manifest bounty
but although the title is in arabic the
poem itself is written in persian it is
written in a poetic form known as the
math navi which is essentially rhyming
couplets this form and the particular
meter used by a tod is the same that
would be adopted by rumi in his great
masterpiece which itself is called the
masnavi navi
so what is this poem all about let's
explore the contents of this great work
the conference of the birds is a poem
about sufism the whole thing is a
metaphorical account of the different
stages of the spiritual path according
to sufi doctrines starting with the
turning away from the desires of the
nafs or self and going through various
stages
eventually reaching the state of union
and subsistence in the divine itself
through annihilating this ego or self
the doctrines of sufism are very complex
and difficult to summarize in short
terms you can advise some of my earlier
episodes for a deeper look into that
topic but in general sufism often
emphasizes the imminence of god in
creation that god can be experienced in
this life by a rigorous spiritual
practice in the more speculative forms
of sufism especially associated with
figures like ibn adabi it is often
thought that god is all that exists in
reality and all quote unquote else is
really a reflection or manifestation of
god
the spiritual path is one of gradually
annihilating the nephs the self or ego
until nothing remains to one's
consciousness but god's very being and
the poem explores all of these themes
through a delightful overarching fable
about birds who go on a long journey
atar begins the poem with an
introduction that sort of sets the stage
for what the work is going to be about
here he praises the prophet muhammad and
it becomes very clear that he sees
himself as a sunni muslim in particular
as he goes on to explicitly praise the
so-called righteous caliphs of abu bakr
umar uthman and ali but this
introduction also gives us some
indications of those classic doctrines
that are often associated with sufism
such as the monistic tendencies that we
can sometimes find in that tradition
just listen to these verses for example
now poetry is always a special case
because it is so dependent on the
original language there is rhyme and
melody that only works in this case in
persian and so no one can of course
experience the poem to the full extent
unless one reads it in the original
language translation is after always
interpretation as it is often said
but in this case there is an amazing
translation by afram darbandi and dick
davis that actually tries to recapture
some of the poetic nature of the
original they have made the poem rhyme
just like in persian and with a
recurring melody i really like this
translation and i will be using it
exclusively when quoting the poem in
this episode so here are a few lions
quote the world is names and science and
truth it's he whose being is its soul
reality
this world the world to come and all
besides are him know this that nothing
else abides
there is one essence but diffused
deflected there is one word but
variously inflected
a man must know the king and recognize
him although a hundred different clothes
disguise him
it's not an error in this way to see him
since he is all and everything must be
him
the error is when a man presumes to
state that what he sees in god are
separate
and after this introduction the actual
narrative of the poem itself starts
the poem recounts the story of all the
birds of the world gathering for a
conference to discuss who they should
appoint as their king something that
proves to be very difficult but then the
huppo which is the wisest of the birds
starts speaking and explains that there
is a great and legendary bird called the
seymourg that lives in a far off land
and that they need to go find this
seamorg to meet their true king
but the way there will be difficult and
plagued with many dangers and obstacles
not everyone will make it but in the end
the journey will be worth it because
they will get to meet their new king
the poem then goes into a new section
where each of the other birds starts
making excuses for why they can't go on
this journey
here each bird represents an aspect of
the nafs or ego that clings to worldly
things one bird is attached to his
possessions another to reputation and so
on in turn each bird expresses their
complaint and excuse and each time the
hupo answers by refuting their
statements pointing out that they are
being misled by the self into ruin he
does this by telling all sorts of
colorful stories many of them taken from
folk tales legends or the lives of
earlier sufis and all of which has a
clear message that critiques the human
tendency to be occupied with the nafs
and the world after all the birds have
presented their excuses and the hupo has
critiqued all of them he manages to
convince a large number of birds to go
on this long journey with him to find
the simorg and just as he warned it
turns out that this journey is filled
with
dangers and it's a very difficult
journey
indeed there are seven valleys that the
birds need to go through to get to their
location and each valley is given its
own section
these valleys are one the valley of the
quest which is the beginning of the
journey when the wayfarer begins to shed
aspects of his life and beliefs
to the valley of love where the birds
lose all sense of reason and instead
enter into a stage of love an important
concept in sufism three the valley of
knowledge where all forms of worldly
knowledge are rendered useless
for the valley of detachment which is a
stage where all attachments that the
self or ego has to the world disappears
the world as we know it is left behind
and we enter into a new kind of
awareness
five the value of unity with the
essential oneness or unity of all things
in god is realized
sixth the valley of bewilderment which
is an important step on the way where
the sufi suddenly experiences a feeling
of uncertainty
somewhat similar to what is known as the
dark knight of the soul in christian
mysticism it is a station of uncertainty
and as the name suggests bewilderment
over all beliefs and assumptions an
important step before the final and
seventh valley is reached which is the
valley of poverty and annihilation this
is essentially what is known as fana and
the sufi tradition it is a total
extinction of the individual self into
the reality of god a realization that
there is nothing but god and that what
we thought was ourself was only a
fleeting fancy
nothing remains but the divine and the
individual has been completely
annihilated this final stage is well
expressed in one of the stories that is
told in the book and a pretty famous
story about the moth and the flame and i
think it's worth quoting this story in
full
quote
moths gathered in a fluttering throng
one night to learn the truth about the
candle's light and they decided one of
them should go to gather news of the
elusive glow one flew till in the
distance he discerned a palace window
where a candle burned and went no nearer
back again he flew to tell the others
what he thought he knew
the mentor of the moth dismissed his
claim remarking he knows nothing of the
flame
a moth more eager than the one before
set out and passed beyond the palace
door
he hovered in the aura of the fire a
trembling blur of timorous desire
then headed back to say how far he'd
been and how much he'd undergone and
seen
the mentor said you do not bear the
signs of one who's fathomed how the
candle shines
another moth flew out his dizzy flight
turned to an ardent wooing of the light
he dipped and sword and in his frenzied
trance both self and fire were mingled
by his dance
the flame engulfed his wingtips body
head his being glowed a fierce
translucent red
and when the mentors saw that sudden
blaze the moths form lost within the
glowing rays he said he knows he knows
the truth we seek that hidden truth of
which we cannot speak
to go beyond all knowledge is to find
that comprehension which eludes the mind
and you can never gain the lung for goal
until you first outsoar both flesh and
soul
but should one part remain a single hair
or drag you back and plunge you in
despair
no creature self can be admitted here
where all identity must disappear
and it is after this valley has been
traversed that the poem reaches its
breathtaking combination
a climax that certainly earns the
permits reputation as one of the most
famous in history after this incredibly
long and difficult journey the birds
arrive at their destination
whereas hundreds of birds set out on the
quest only 30 birds make it all the way
to the realm of the seymourg now
remember that number
30 tired and devoted birds that are now
aching to meet their king
as they arrive a kind of guardian
appears to greet them and after
questioning them deems that they are
indeed ready to meet the seymourg
so he leads them to a gate and unlocks
it behind which lies the answer to all
their desires
but as they reach that final point of
their journey they are not met with some
great majestic bird
instead they find themselves staring
into a reflection
a reflection of themselves
here atar reveals the great pawn that
lies at the heart of the whole story
the persian word seymourg si morg
literally means thirty birds
they are the semurg the goal of their
quest turns out not to have been some
big powerful bird or something but the
innermost core of their own being in the
classic sufi way they are met with the
reality that god is all that there is
god is not something that can be found
out there somewhere but in one's own
heart as the essence of one's own being
again i feel like it's worth quoting
this section at length from the
beautiful translation by that bandian
davis quote
there in the seymour's radiant face they
saw themselves the simulg of the world
with awe
they gazed and dared at last to
comprehend they were the semorg and the
journey's end
they see the semorg at themselves they
stare and see a second seymour standing
there
they look at both and see the two are
one that this is that that this the goal
is one
they ask but inwardly they make no sound
the meaning of these mysteries that
confound
their puzzled ignorance how is it true
that we is not distinguished here from
you
and silently their shining lord replies
i am a mirror set before your eyes
and all who come before my splendor see
themselves their own unique reality
you came as thirty birds and therefore
saw these self same 30 birds not less
nor more
if you had come as 40 50 here and
answering 40 50 would appear
though you have struggled wandered
traveled far it is yourselves you see
and what you are
who sees the lord it is himself each
sees
what anne's side could discern the
pleiades what anvil could be lifted by
an ant or could a fly subdue an elephant
how much you thought you knew and saw
but you now know that all you trusted
was untrue
though you traversed the valley's depths
and fought with all the dangers that the
journey brought the journey was in me
the deeds were mine you slept secure in
beings in most shrine
and says you came as thirty birds you
see these thirty birds when you discover
me the seymour truth's last flawless
jewel the light in which you will be
lost to mortal sight
dispersed to nothingness until once more
you find in me the selves you were
before
then as they listened to the seamorg's
words a trembling dissolution filled the
birds
the substance of their being was undone
and they were lost like shade before the
sun
neither the pilgrims nor their guide
remained the seymour ceased to speak and
silence reigned
it's
absolutely breathtaking even in
translation
the story then goes on for a little
while more to some degree emphasizing
that after fana or annihilation comes
what is known as baka or
subsistence in god where one returns to
oneself but with a kind of newfound
perspective on reality based on that
experience of union and of annihilation
you can probably tell why this has
become such a classic right through the
very dramatic overarching story of the
birds and their journey as well as
through the shorter stories spread
throughout which are often very
light-hearted and funny telling tales of
lovers animals kings and dervishes the
poem manages to capture some of the most
profound ideas and concepts in sufism
through a narrative that is very
engaging and beautifully written the
imagery that atar weaves really enhances
the impact of these ideas and transports
the reader into a different realm
all the parts of the tale represent an
aspect of sufism the birds are of course
us humans and the different desires and
attachments that we have to the world
the hupo represents the wise sufi sheikh
who leads his student on the spiritual
path to god
that path is of course represented by
the journey that the birds go on and the
seven valleys represent these stages or
stations that the sufi adept will go
through in the process of purifying his
soul on the way to union
the simulg is god the absolute reality
who turns out in the end to be imminent
in all things reality and ourselves only
being a reflection of his infinite being
this poem for good reason left a major
impact and mark on later persian poetry
and on sufism in general as we've stated
previously rumi was incredibly
influenced by a todd and the conference
of the birds and he probably used it as
an inspiration for his own magnificent
work called the mas navi
aside from rumi many other later
thinkers would often use much of the
imagery that atar creates in this poem
and
a lot of the same style of expressing
many of these sufi ideas come from this
poem originally even outside of islam
and sufism
even someone like baha'u'llah the
founder and prophet of the baha'i faith
wrote a work called the seven valleys
which as you can tell just by the name
is basically
entirely based on the story and the
conference of the birds it's often
referenced in culture today and there
are music albums named after the poem
narratives that take the same basic form
and much more at thor remains one of the
most famous names in sufism and in
persian poetry
while we don't know much about his life
the incredible poems that he gave us are
enough to cement him as an incredibly
important figure in history hopefully
now you understand why just
retelling the basic plot of this story
kind of gives me the feels there's no
secret that
i really like this work
and i really recommend that you check it
out too it's a
magnificent piece of literature and
especially if you're interested in
sufism it's an absolutely beautiful
expression of many of those core ideas
from that tradition if you know persian
then you are luckier than me and you
should probably pick it up in the
original language and experience that
true
melody and rhyme of this poem but even
in translation it's an incredibly
engaging and beautiful work of course
because i've been quoting from that
translation in particular in this
episode i recommend the translation by
darbandi and dick davis but there are
other translations out there as well i
look forward to exploring more of the
classics of sufi literature with you
guys and of course there is a lot to
explore there so
we have a lot of fun stuff ahead of us
for now i thank you so much for watching
this episode um thank you as always to
my patrons who support this channel
monetarily
feel free to leave a comment to like the
video subscribe to the channel if you
feel like i deserve it and i'll see you
next time
[Music]
you